[Music]
Bleacher Report is innovative because we
get to talk about sports like the fans
that we are we're not inserting
ourselves into the conversation we are
the conversation we are the sauce we're
swagoo all day a br we come up with an
idea we brainstorm and then within a
couple of hours it's across all of the
ARS platforms really comes down to us
just figuring out what is the best
possible journey for the user to really
drive the conversation around those
moments that anything that we think
about that can resonate with our
audience that has ties to pop culture
sports entertainment anything that our
audience and we think is cool and we can
create we will you can walk BR tell
stories that stick to your bones the
kind of stuff that you'd want to share
in your group chat or pass your cell
phone of your friend if you like yo did
you see this
the r came to us and we pitched them on
gamers owns which is a mash-up of Game
of Thrones and the NBA and bleacher
report said great soon it was all over
the Internet
dudes guys it allowed us to really push
the way that we and everyone else are
talking about sports through cartoons
and through humor and through a
different form of storytelling
so I'm starting an Instagram account
called houses highlights and after a few
months I was gaining some attention and
BR recognized that and they thought what
I was doing was unique and different
they brought me in they believed in me
and they they got out of the way and
they said hey Omar we want you to be
yourself and that really helped bring
house of Heights that next level @br we
owned the moments
and our audience recognizes that when
you're sitting with your group of
friends and somebody asks you did you
see that game last night somebody's
gonna say did you see what we tree board
did that's the thing that gets people
talking that's the thing that people
really want to see that's the difference
between us and everybody else
[Applause]
[Music]
you